monsieur vous êtes le responsable du
centre nautique du rhône y at il
beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui je compte qu'on va fusiller
9 80 s beaucoup dans l'absolu oui la
piscine à nos personnels saturé votre
record bat le record à 7 et les
premières années d'ouverture du centre
nautique qui a été onze mille personnes
pour le mois de juillet ça fait combien
d'entrées en moyenne ben faut tenir
compte du mauvais temps parce qu'on n'a
pas eu le goût juillet n'a pas été
épatant les premières semaines
alors je compte moi une moyenne d'entrée
de 3500 personnes par jour je pense que
vous comptez vous rattraper avec les
nocturnes avec le continuation du beau
temps mais il faudrait pour responsable
si on compte se rattraper en fait le
maximum on est on est tributaire du beau
temps c'est agréable de venir note qu
après sur l'anr